well u.s president donald trump is due
to visit california on monday to meet
with heads of
emergency services who've been
overseeing efforts to battle the
unprecedented fires there
days of dry and windy conditions have
been feeding dozens of blazes across
california oregon and washington state
their wildfires have killed at least 35
people's
people and officials are warning of
possible
more fatalities dw's washington bureau
chief inis paul reports
from northern california where thousands
of people who were evacuated are now
returning
to scenes of utter devastation
nothing but destruction this is all that
is left on the five acres of farmland
in northern california where sarah
hawkins and her husband have created a
little paradise over the last
17 years took only four hours before
everything was destroyed left are only
shards of memories
her grandmother's good china items
they collected over decades the fire was
coming across
short grass it was coming across dirt
there was no place that we knew for sure
would be safe
here in this barn sarah lost all her 17
baby goats to the flames
we didn't have time to hook up the
trailer
we didn't know that we were in
any kind of danger no fires ever moved
this fast out here
ever you know and when we came back the
next day
i'll never forget seeing the burned
bodies
in the barnyard people like sarah who
are living in this part of the world
are used to wildfires but they have
never experienced something
like this year there are multiple mega
fires
burning millions of acres
have been destroyed millions of
residents have to live in
toxic air the whole west coast
seems on fire some climate experts say
climate change is smacking california
in its face in clermont
we speak with the director of
environmental analysis
char miller human beings are driving
climate change they're driving it
because in fact we're on cars in
southern california and elsewhere
that we're pumping effluents into the
air that's heating up the planet and the
atmosphere
and so when the fires start burning
they're actually burning as a result of
our own actions
sarah hawkins is not willing to give in
and is
already building a newborn knowing
that the next fire might take everything
away again
you